Or sit in the ears. C.E.C. Years between Sydney and Cambridge. If you still must you. Nice to meet Tom's ears is this.
Split marriage and I want you to do the best you know that was that she would be to good schools to. Hear this is.
What did you. There's a pretty low class at the Straits and.
In later I got out of there as quickly as I possibly could and in the light a lot for lived at the end cross paths.
Paddington. In that area.
I was working came home to fall of the country tried and discovered that most of the the guy played used to.
Meet in our park every not this is during the war. These were cratering. Yes in Sydney for that you would have.
Yes Years east toward the east.
Yeah there are those medically unfit for the previous year
or so I think that was in the light part of the year in the east.
And I was in the pipe in tried most of the year without a say but all the year.
The guy played police even leading a rain hard every day not this was your first experience. We know or lace Yes.
They'd make their on the states
and they would have bought her she wanted the red have parties all fresco course there was a lot of sorting around the
pathways with the ground round the sample and there was a young place cadets resting at least two
or three every night they were the place cadets would get their room.
But night wobble they Beyond's and for entrapment.
And they'd be at least a couple arrested Renard course in those days they were getting three months in jail for
rustlers sitting this floor was slight arrived and and talk on the air the lawful soliciting only pertained to.
Pimps and prostitutes
and it was ruled in the in the court that you could slip another main could solicit another man for himself.
That was cost to them. Another one with broad day in which covered the decency then. Not long after that there was.
People getting caught in drag their fears that was overturned because it was an.
They used to be offensive that a person was dressed in women's clothes it was a humorous
but wasn't offensive providing they weren't soliciting in as a woman
and then the one to one accusations in the court that was also overt and because well that is not cooperation.
Anyone can make in the could accuse anyone else for her sexually when it didn't exist.
Earlier was a number of these returning a little
but any right in the park there was anyone could a role if they were the couple bottles of plonk
and would sit in the park and.
And everyone had known the plumes of course in the old days there were such people is because the Russian mole floors
the hour. Isabella Ilana McQuade Carson. Forever Ramba. Oh incidentally although the Russian model of the winter.
Karun won a military middle. Years for brightly. A couple of years ago. What was involved at the Chinese is something.
But anyway there was always characters and nice to sit in the city on the seats and greet plank and dance over the.
And carry on regardless Lee of course the place to. Buy periodical rides through the park.
One was a big fat bubble gum Sargent and and we have to run through the Baucus and Mary's Cathedral layer of the day
and of the mind to get away from them.
Usually they names and addresses
but we've even more force ones anyway they'd be someplace in Sydney where they'd have stacks
and stacks of false names and addresses but the position was then if you did give a true nine Crist's
and place of work.
The boss of a phone call the next day and you'd be dismissed or got three lost three jobs three it's.
Cooking in Whitey.
In the catering trade or in Sydney and when this board
and the place stopped this publication in the truth at close was. At the we was it in. The Hotel in Sydney. Yeah.
The green cynical course it's Italy was it what at the end of the sect on the spot on the Monday morning.
Yeah well this is of this.
Is that was the year the publication of the truth
but in the raw yet I discovered in still in the parks the gardens building.
In the lead of the family which had a sunken roof a little bit a four foot sunken roof on the top.
So I discovered if we could put on the saw it in the place into the park we could run up there.
Get beyond these but the parapet in the place of rod
and starts joining torches around where the does this affect bubble bum sides and see it with a the bastards go
and I go at Assad to go at the park and we all. Let him go.
Brain I'm at the park and I come sundering back smashing through all the all the shrubbery and breaking flares
and all that and one of the sergeants and the bass of the rap of the crazy one. We'll get to you. Cards. Can't wait.
Now you're up there with the trophies.
If you're ever going to hoard have a look at that in the shade I think they've got a lot of war
and stuff on top of it and that small as we used to call to score a lot growth.
It was a wonderful place we could sit up they have a dozen of us and replant you know like a number
and I was the old one o'clock in the morning.
So it was always Oh yes all the people writing
and even light coming from the shows that we waiting at St James' station for the trains and that.
And they do all the singing careers in going on in the parking lot so we rightly in the front of the book if it's I
didn't know what these people were we thought we were Luminol for my thoughts but it's
but mediately they call the place. This is the place it comes through.
Of course it was arraigned a bit larger in the four. Just before the end of the world just shortly.
Just or in that town where there was two detective sergeants was on the public the public toilet late
and I accosted the main public toilet and accused him of indecency and they pulled him aside
and said Now for a certain amount of money even if you get all of it is
and because you were exposing yourself in the public told him to do it at those. At the Juran. The only way.
The fellow is along with this and he said Well I haven't got the money on me but I will.
HAVE A Tomorrow night a way can we meet. So we use the meeting place was Julie. There Rob.
And after a short conversation the money was handed over and then an inspector placed popped out of the blue.
He'd recorded all the conversation and he singles Siegel rather than your place to movie.
Rock mission coming out of it and the two detectives were.
Just dismissed from the force but they put but I think they had a better twenty four of years each in superannuation.
So they put down the drive in the main it was nameless Makai.
And he was the London native there of the telegraph and he'd just come from a city dealing with this war if
and he left a momentary momentarily in the car. To go to the top to relieve yourself in that pic a very nasty.
It was extortion was there an explosion. But anyway you are saying the great lead for an organized.
Get together as you know with a bit of music and fraud he said he not Benson and promised to do the release wiki
and done nothing. Makes a resource that for getting things only way.
US evolved or does it all get a hole in an old poster.
So all the noise this within the play tend it's got a booking at the glade ten whole rang the blarney says instituted
as the heavenly blonde musicians you know will tell them to do stuff that if they won bonus was of course I couldn't
say but we're talking super model but still don't know like the big is the selves that blow
and sell just you know like even two birds to kill one stand but only right now bury you. Where was that head the.
Pretty good because the news of the to the Truth newspaper was sniffing a range.
And asking questions and who would Martin weigh at this time in the form of Steve's all secret. No. What a new.
All up with having stage personnel and radio personalities literally cracking Minnick to get an invitation.
It was that sacred
and everyone was very bohemian like let the devil take the test these days you have six they are some of the sleaze all
all it is become black. But then there was a certain man to secrecy and is rather different.
So anyway I ordered the whole Anyway I walked in the Australia. The straight out tail of the too long.
And set the morning in just the stupid of the invitations
and one says How the hell can we get the if we don't with good hits. Tell you said the moon.
In its own way but the not guilty agent.
So I walked in there set him only Where is it glued kennels starts died clock cost
and it was a rush everyone at get you know they have to run it and get things and people have to go
and get their week's done up and all this sort of business and and dregs of the usually only worn sacred bread
and on and up the river hall to the. There was the archbishop of camper Rob He was of the from Priest. Or somebody.
I think was a little boy says something that some church. He'd rather to six foot candle sticks.
I don't know where we caught him from. And he was in full regalia. And we've of course had the wedding in N.F.L.
Broad and six broad my. And as they come from the supper room up.
They sprinkled all the perfect him over them and all that sort of business and there was Dolly dimples
and it was Georgie and we had some old lesbians there also they were in Texas these days and.
Yes it was very full most of them. And they provided a couple of thoughts during the night as. Terry close in that but.
Then Tony Moore It's Tony Tony then would be willing to use fifty's course we're only twenty's. And. Tony would do.
He's famous Rose of Picotee course.
Tony was one of the all smart said diggers in the not in fortnight in ball in the Smart League is the show
and Tony struck the as I've been told by other already is that he'd stop the shower.
Convalescent came in France were at a theater in the grand finale he walked to the back.
With a criminal in with a large basket of roses
and threw them into the audience singing Rose if so of course this was is this was these usual song. And it's. Very.
Oh yes Tony
or tourney he'd be year he'd be in the six fifties lights for sixty's series a bigger in the First World War
and of course those times just after the war there was the Trocadero in Sydney they had the big artist in their pursuit.
Event that the gave in to the course there was no other place to go if there was even a coffee shop open for gay people
like the shutters had come down within twenty four hours. So anyway.
Ray cleverly was always always one the the belle of the ball either Roy playing technican with this messy crinoline
and hard headed we in the we get headlights in it was operated by a bet recently
and a mess of costume always the political course it was a lot of jealousy associated with right cleverly so can.
I'm a race with these things. Gratian darling twenty models said I'll give that bastard something for each corner.
So one night we went window shopping Sunday night in the city the neighbors the window display of a bed a dozen stuff.
Birds of Paradise and peacocks.
The next thing of course I wasn't involved at all
but the next morning I heard that there'd been a special grab in the center of the city.
And the place the completely mystified.
They was all the birds the wind moldy al the and leave the place didn't know what to make of it
but at the next start as ball a rock magnificent You ought to say he was preggers from head to toe.
He looked like the really lit the royalist the ship. He was Fred as if with. Belittle. Claudia.
Nearly got pink to the next year because he arrived he was defended in twenty fifth as he rubbed with the with the
Benton rooster on his head place his lawyers and in the truth.
The next day although a couple of days after it was the Irish place E.I.O.
To question him a bit using laws of the race but. Ice in the great need for the East after the.
After the Vivian Leigh's waiting at the gate in will and it was full broad
and begged all the the two to Dole is been ZWAR attacks the days and tiles
and there's a new nine weeks ago our little red took two together.
Is a pretty don't leave that's the name that's tonight you see a lot of these old guy street names of gone in all
extinct buttons or lower. Suburban type whom don't change to live the underpants. They sticky buns.
But then after that they all seem to come out of the bloody wood work after the Vivian lady waiting there was the ashes
in the city there's ashes and. The carton. Suppose the. Everyone wanted to learn to do was a complete mystery.
You know what was going on because when then it took off this was in not in forty five. After that run of the Eureka.
Hall is a small predicate and it was the original youth.
Communist party youth all around that Christ's birth and fear scares of fights.
The bottles and people getting the dregs torn off and all that but that's all. When it was part and parcel of it.
Over there was part and parcel everyone enjoyed the. You know a bit of rough.
Yes there was none of the silver tea service with us.
Is it was rough and ready and all that and everyone enjoyed it and. Of course they even was next in Basin. X. Eighteen.
Next thing thought she was going to rue St The pool by the Sydney's Elsom next.
The toys there and there was one of the med I'm Stan at Woolloomooloo.
Was having a birthday party next in the saga to hold it was a nice fall over North Sydney of Norse Sydney station a
reception room for weddings that will not nastily point and put in a random everybody that.
At one of the medals down at Woolloomooloo
and all the lady crackers then they were all ladies of easy virtue of going to have a nice party.
It was going to be a HOT. The only very selected guest and thought. Mildred was up from Melbourne wanted to go and.
Lantern the parks it not for bloody man if Mexicans are running it seem to be a genius and I think the next cut.
I wene why Iraq was moved from Melbourne and we had the people going and we paid six shillings in
and we had three bottles of cloth is always part of the party's plan you know. So I walked into the room.
We walked in there was an hour quoting at the pain of the cabbage Rose grained plying with something from years of
comedy.
And Mildred System eleven with this bloody mob with their cross she said this party once a midnight in the room was a
bad bet twenty year prostitutes that fifteen of the pimps. Kin. List to thirty dollars please bins in the girlfriends.
I bet twenty.
Greg Queens and the boyfriends and a bad bet thirty not the bats were in the cross
and to add a little bit of flavor to it all Casablanca star. To Tory's gun. Day where they will government done.
So anyway. We've got to me the wind Russell resolve this isn't proper shops and at saw the wind was ignoring.
I said if the worst comes was a straight A A through doing the wrong on the warning and jumped to the Great.
Because I could see it was a couple of drunks couple of the not a bad assed in any way the kike a rod the cane
Elizabeth a shame pine everyone saying happy birthday one mall try to sing a song and fell over.
And anyway as the not progressed to the best get
and Vivien Leigh she was in Greg walked past in one of the not of that scrape the week we were Canterbury keyed it was
the release this old used to fart for Randall's of the city. No nuns.
In the Canterbury get floor fusion large of punches
and not the not a bad day end table splintering in the smashing of glass We're both from that on went on any way the
fight was on and the bad language was all the moles the malls the bad language and Paki was axed. And anyway.
There were frying bottles in the mirrors on the walls being smashed up was lovely. It was rough.
They are seen now before that play out in the dance of the seven Viles this is the last.
Slip the way they click the lights had just to leave enough to reach.
Then then the next of the hot to the uproar mixing got on the dice
and called Ladies Ladies please don't throw the bottles
and chairs please ladies will you please place older they bit at the core.
Anyway mixing go to the like I call them the face whipped off the weed and mixing the six foot through in a big long
and joined in the fart Romanesque who got knocked out in one slithering along with four engraved with a dress up
or A and B. but She had no one to paint so in this. It was a.
Moving time to go through the winder up and running around to see all in the air.
And just as we got through the window of the gunnies the lodge went out again on the ganas lit floor over the joints
two tons of flame in the room to. The shut to shut fart in the box as if at least I'm getting it.
So we run along the the orning was too far to drop to the dish so there was another wind direction.
Sosa Quick's Arcus see the whole lot through the door.
Why it is that it was another flat children more screaming from the occupants didn't we.
We've run look at this bit of still a bottle of water up to no Sydney station and Mildred. She said give you a.
To a social class they've only special guests were lucky to get his vehicle.
Was to look back it is still a screaming in the smashing of bottles and the police car off and that was
when it was very one of. Mixing Benson's evenings. Of course next in it at any rental party after.
I think there's a better sales and hands damage was all noisy take the nature.
You know mirrors on the wall and someone fell into the into the baby grand piano.
Then there was the Gaiety Ballroom around that there was in not in forty nine after this truth.
Tonight it's out and there was the rest. So hold it more like that was northern forty seven.
Then there was the Hollywood tennis courts hall that was in forty nine. That was. There was also in Concord.
And there was the another to turn it in forty seven of the larger hall of believe that this lovely.
There was a frost that was in very little bit. So the fog.
But it paid for the orchestra and it was bring your own of course there was still ahead bet far past parties included.
There was there was a large cast a that was left to have
and there was the white lifters so the whole Could Gee that that was dandy the year that it was a small
but it was very nice beat cranky ever in the bar the best three o'clock in the morning
and it was the best on the Balmoral big party. This was really something. It was very. It was very.
Very risque and it would have you know I've got someone contacted me either.
His name was meek he does the game leave the lead arrive.
Every crossness way so he said No you said Bring a few feel your friends a reset for.
This is to pick a dozen of them obese Navarrete and if it loses all four plod in
and we'll never know our story came to a bit of music and in a lucky. As it now Bash now beshrew owner.
He said Oh I run the ship it really is on the game later. But he getting close. Probably chief.
You know with the ruby ours isn't it would take three. So I can take. Susan places that did. It was the.
Doris sweeps away day. And oh that was six dogs that.
Well there wasn't going to be a party of twenty or so when we arrived at the till it was a bit.
Forty fifty young lads from that area all whitey to get out and she hears the wind up. He said to Jesus.
See I'm uneasy. The only way we can get a house that hard to get into build but each day get up in a little G.
and Go there was people bodies strictures went into the breach to if the police would rob the route it wouldn't do to
Peter. That was the Belmore of bleach it. Written a bit that there was.
And of course of course if they was Russell Norton's finest little parties that ran the crusts which crossing I'd been
there for at least a dozen times to this it first two straight then there was another all the hast standbys water right
where he had the kep the co-chairs at the back. It was night it was a stable.
Yes night it into your in our studio and of course. With her friend it was a fella called green glass.
I think it was the city now. He was described boy at the gay people as Nashville and we make listen.
Well when we division these lul day insisted nothing on you going to stay in the mess killer would make innocent.
So there was always there was always place driving at rallies places that confiscating photographs of course green
glass was the that the model for me had a very athletic body for years and she'd point even rude
and put a big Graeme's head or a bull's head on it.
Which was incapable of course of the heat of the subject and the place was the objection objectionable an obscene
and public talking of the days when even the.
The nude from the Sydney gallery were moved Lindsay's paintings were you removed from the Sydney gallery a gallery is
being obscene the civic fathers
and bluenoses even ordered that the that the year of the classical Greek statues in the Sydney botanical gardens have
masonry figleaves fitted to protect the morals of the little kiddies. It was and I both on the third week.
I even suggested the people memorial phantom be covered with some sort put under paints
and go on the inner of the chase and centaurs and they centaurs in that underpants be placed on them.
It was absurd
and now of course we all know about that terrible author who wrote a lovely silence that practically nailed him to the
cross and to guide us it's really very odd that book. Wrote Rosie I'd never say nothing gives. Nothing.
Rossi Nortons price that suggested black masses in the press this always pushing these.
Black masses and the devil worship but no no no no. It was all a rush. The media came T. It was all the plank.
If you lock a little bit on the sargent lying around in the cushions and lean since burning
and it was other strange aromatic too if you wished. Of course the Americans introduced us to this.
I think they called it Potter to Luna or something like smoke smoke it a part of it.
And turns up in the cause we get happened to a rough day incident green glass had come at the head a monkey in the
snake it will be in the day but there is.
The Eagles close in a few bottles of the preserves but there is nothing like black nests they pull ridiculous.
Own very heavily God loved loved gay people and on the dollar of rallies that was.
All Russell Norton this year who could see what was it. Oh yes you Chris.
Oh yes three years roll is what was in was one
or two very important a guy paid for years because Rosie was Roee all Rosie was before her time.
To love the Evan guy the the Belle he. In her subsequently pieties. Quite famous one part of a wooden rose in winter.
You get sick to death of the persecution Sydney went to South Australia
and held an exhibition over there in was arrested for obscene paintings bought places. And then the angel can.
Bishop of Adelaide who bought one and he started in cotton wool the tells the court that.
The evil was in the arms of the holder that he he thought it was great or that there was nothing there to Paul.
There's nothing suggestive see if you look at something. It was a general episode totally up to the person.
The only way that they didn't. Rosie was that they were very very evident it was over before they put on.
Is there a trick. Choosing a very unusual piece is usually has a safe. Because she called a spade a spade.
She would never mean store fritted was with us what she meant she met and that was it but.
If she fancies you should want to she'd put it straight away to be painted in the know it.
But her mind was great as he was not that sort of that it can speculative. Then the rest of it.
That was the place it was the music placed in a little rose straight Sydney.
It was a music's you simple rooted music studio is involved in the student piano. It's all there's a place you go.
They have a set. They know it and strip off and lay around on the captions in and burn incense and listen to class.
It was a big to harbor. At the edge to resign. But it all ended up in that. Rock.
Of sorts that was in Little Rock Street and there was a taint ring tendering started. Going against it.
Fifty one had done later show and. About anywhere else in the lane Lord next door coming out of the shotgun and.
Start far easier shots and. So I just get this straight.
Oh noes the roast roast great was was there a series of rooms in the large building was like an academy you know if
they all had root to teach volley in piano and all that but one large studio catches a ramp
and you get down the oversexed they know I can take a bottle of plonk in that now
but no dancing now I read a bit you could just lie around and just fainted in the ninety's. And. It was yes.
But that was back to the interests of all of them and some inner city and they were one of the could play the piano.
It was a very special. Business. Now not only. Were you talking at the time. Practicing cigarettes the spirit.
Oh and the end of the roast roast straight. They'd be on the bed pretty good. They're very sexual. Yes this is.
Yes early fifty's Tri-State diverse large building. Their Own. Piano Bar. There's this different group.
You know at the top where like going to make you know a lot of nice touch pics of Bollywood classics. Let me.
John Smiths
and I just had about building a big goals case smelling of style you're on where you want to go again you know there
was the we got to the the the Golden Circle which was all the girls
and so it was all professional men from this is what I did a lot
and he wanted to know the nature of the from he wanted me to do that it was more like to come up the Middle East
and I wasn't terribly pleased with it. This is locked away. I'll tell you what. One.
I ended up a Supreme Court judge
and it was several barristers just couple of specialist doctors from Corey straight to.
One case they were there was one magistrate the senators came to me to was trying to pick the one that before you break
even the minimum and then there's remembers the his representatives one of them. One of them.
Jordan from where we were going to go. To Gollum's they had a cruise. They had a large.
A large American vessel border raised by i go of that have to boyfriends and I get a cruise at the parametric river.
It was that not all of cover of law.
It's all you can drag it was very and shame party course are going to be brought into one of them at economy so.
Typical.
Course the rough
and ready to go during this is the super tease of this which hits the related deaths you know looks just to.
Too much silver of the gold and the gold and says.
Of course we're there we're here at one of them had an apartment at the building which up.
Now with the stink part is the clear Petra's needle in our.
Building which obviously they're very they're old unit spirits and the truth.
Reporter to was that there was a spy in the midst meets.
One dollar a week off
and stayed on the place it would have to color the leaves for the course of those two big men Peaches the barrister.
But
but after that the year the truth spread eagled this all over the pages you know there's so you could say bolt on them
to let the golden city start to get around the park and. My better be very discreet.
They used to come in and they was full of the day he was managing director of he was one of the to do.
Here at the mic at the pink ass at McLean Regis you question it. Sure it.
Required Regis at that those days was the push to eat
and he said he we are WAS TALKING TO YOU IN THE LEAD THE in this trial your barrister The little bastard this case is
making the end of the Elizabeth on the jetty ERISA the talking man he said The next morning news to their usual giving
forth pay only so that was a lot of money.
He said in the country says Give me one hundred so called The first places a walk up the little circular to eat cause
he was a managing director of one of the guys department stores in the city
but he he was one of the year the golden circle and then there was the blong Queens or make one of the Cup a year ago.
The only boys. George does not know it will be better. Lives up in. The boys will draw as to the way.
They beat the sixty's to near zero shore used to leave. Dan Warfield these.
Util up came in and Bella represent Bella this. Is Bella was said Rose's protege.
ROSE There was a very wealthy who lived in Warfield gardens.
Close boy lived to Bill Mahoney and of course that was Mr and Mrs Will Money magazine. Josh flats and Rose loved.
It became a she said Dan She had a full grand piano beautiful apartment
and went to talk with the she'd met for the sherry and sit down and she'd sing in force a sing in numbers.
That was down at the bottom a clash of course was not a.
Of course
and if you want to go to the mall risk i places they was the chicken in the basket is in a week ago that was held in a
very exclusive.
Saturday Green Park point where I had a washing basket with the bottom cut out after three wraps and
when the party was well underway and everyone was drunk and I had a chicken.
If you couldn't take the real booze that naturists hold to combat they would be placed in the basket with the use of
butchers will come the roof that have a hole in the thoroughly.
And then like the basket up with chicken in it and then.
Well you can imagine what happens when they but a few did luckily best to June avoid amount of pleasure
and plenty of wine and genial then getting very drunk and they developed a chicken in the basket.
You see them wandering around the cross the next morning staggering. The course the didn't know which one.
Is there is another chicken got.
He's been in the basket all its And course there was the year the spoof part is that for Jews not the large not the
large place of course beautiful picture where you just. You get forty or fifty they are in the year nine.
And as a certain tone the master SARA Mr Cohen is the spokesman going to this only one a watchman there for three
minutes where you describe can place you close will get will you knew where you use in the range of the start of the
end.
The back of the only the major place where where you put your clothes
and then in the year the master centers around his singing at.
And then everyone rich or random the doctor where you got you got. Said to young it was young.
Bryce Kelley and you didn't remember truck price Grace Kelly tended to be notorious gun.
And usually that couple notably. And. Going to meet. And.
And our citizens utilize one of these parties Gus He said now that he said this is the second big leg to Margret me.
So anyway I eventually went to the party in a really big Gladiator didn't grab a quick look back and he took a dart.
But when. There was another party Dan Dan and. Parts point you going to.
It was a large I think was a painter Yes you go into one of the large master bedroom she take all the gear off
and more you was there. You put on the scene rather mask.
As I told you before I was a mage on this occasion because frogs fairies elves all that sort of thing. And.
As you read about that looked long after they were so you.
Eugene Goossens got arrested with the customs for having a quantity of mask
and other rather large is a nice bag each coming back from overseas another party D.L. That was the sign.
Stood around in the role of this mix party gays and whatever.
And all the haven't got people and you think chambers used to create Lee in the nude
and whatever he wanted to do you done.
You just asked was quite up front in a small pool long meaningful conversations that late night where you didn't really
ask what you wanted to you got nobody was allowed to leave together. The beauty of this. That the next day.
Jesus walked past some hours that party would be Clay.
And he would know who they were that was the beautiful part of unusual and in unlimited. You know what was it go.
Yes and. Of course there was so there was a rush. He once said which oh no that was.
It was Father Greg quite easily a couple of the joining straight. There was a rush of.
Show ponies and we did with the tails in minds missing who was hit in the paper it was the after the. And they didn't.
One was.
Used to two Pablo ponies with lovely long minds in the tails getting ready for the royalties to show
or going to exploring the. Bob of course.
These were made in two weeks that his horse their heads would substitute of course on top ending in them.
Those we could cost a hundred fifty two hundred was naturally two hundred pounds two hundred
and was imported from Italy. That's when the girls of silver here before they got married to citrus that any questions.
Any questions. It's all the rice to the rivers rivers is there was one young. He just out of his apprenticeship.
And he he was he was guy in the he's a very. It was. It was another surprise that Graeme like priciest.
He said he said this is this is the young jockeys rice for the. Course always suspected it was all lies.
There's always one on the program that really breathed
and he said no you don't want the world to not just have it all just to play in the year that he was gay at.
And that things that goes on in life styles it tells a few stories.
Where we got the information the not for the doctors there was a panic in bus on the walls he was going to leave the
bagman released briefcase inside the mind gated rain which we all got into the panic and as each person Rog.
I put the money into that briefcase and noted book by book they contributed and he got wind of the ring
and got seven to one. Well you were saying the Reisa did look from the start because we knew it was wrong.
It wasn't very much kicking down your honor. When that.
The horse coming around the series the barrier the horse hit the front of the back six and run
and come over the Royce and stay there in the seat of the other jockeys when to crawl into or to kick today that.
Not it was so obvious
but what led in the give him a good lead in the try to catch up in court costs a lot at the end
and it irks put a soprano you lost a ticket course everyone that we find it.
And they were in the smaller than healed up to take it there was no gaiety shapers in the first day and.
It was only when we did
but we never sent in a couple times after that park used to have a briefcase with a bottle of scotch in it. Noise.
Classes and. He strained and of course also in the park there was there was a couple of a couple of our friends they.
Reputed towards in the ballet were. Was it the Ballet Russe or the belly full surely.
And they actually deigns to the same company is. In. And. They were obviously you're a pain to.
And that's they succumb to the love the came in the pack in a local scandal and these. Parties want to leave and.
They said he used to float like a beautiful but. Wouldn't it be or could imagine.
But anyway but he was supposed to be made to it wasn't. That these was pleased with the days when.
Everything was so secret about the guy a mafia. Because of the.